this is an incredibly moving story for
the very first time Massachusetts
congresswoman Ayanna Presley is publicly
revealing a personal battle she is
facing watch impeachment Eve the last
little bit of my hair came out this is
my official public revealing I'm ready
now because I want to be freed from the
secret and the shame that that secret
carries with it
so this is a new video interview that
she did with the roote Presley reveal
she has alopecia the autoimmune disease
can result in total hair loss Presley
said she wanted to be transparent about
her diagnosis since her signature hair
twists have become part of her personal
and political brand and she went on to
say this guy's I felt naked exposed
vulnerable I felt embarrassed ashamed
betrayed also that I was participating
in a cultural betrayal because of all
the little girls who write me letters
come up to me take selfies with me
hashtag twist nation yeah she said I
felt like I owed all those girls little
girls an explanation right here matters
and with the crown act which is like a
rights act to make sure that women are
judged at the workplace for how they
wear their hair you know it's it's an
important message she sent it I will say
she looks powerful and potent as ever
looks terrific she said this started
right in the fall I think in it and then
accelerated very quickly yeah six point
two six point eight million Americans
are affected by alopecia according to
the alopecia areata foundation it's not
life-threatening but the hair loss guys
huge psychological